نحن نناشد الذين لم يلتحقوا بهذا الاتفاق
ان يلتحق الان الاطار حقيقه اصبح خطوه من
الماضي ولم لم يعود الكلام فيه نون
الالتحاق بالاتفاق الايطالي ولكن
بقيه المسار والخطوات اللاحقه وصولا
للاتفاق النهائي تمر عبر ورشه ومؤتمرات
القضايا وهذه يجب ان يشارك فيها الجميع
حركه تحرير السودان وحركه العدل والمساواه
هم فقط الحركتين اللي لم ينضموا الاتفاق
بقيه كل الحركات الواقعه على الاتفاق
اليابا هي جزء من الاتفاق نحن مازلنا
بنعمل انهم يجوا ينضموا همم لركب الاتفاق
لانه قطع اشواط وطبعا اتراجع هذا
الاتفاق الى الوراء لانه اي انتكاسه فيه
او اي تنصل منه بيعني انه احنا هندخل مره
اخرى في دوامه الاضطراب وعدم الاستقرار
الاطار حكم رمي الديمقراطي هذا جوهره
اتفاقينا احنا عملنا في هذه الاتفاقيه
نعلم الجوهره وهذه الاتفاقيه مهمه وهذه
العمليه بما في ذلك التفكيك مهم لكل اهل
السودان وبالذات في مناطق النزاعات والحرب
ولذلك من المفيد ان تحسم هذه القوى امرها
لكي نصل الى مراتي جديده في تنفيذ اتفاقيه
السلام الخطوات تقترب من الوصول للاتفاق
النهائي الذي يجمع السودانيين ويوحدهم خلف
حكومه مدنيه وقياده مدنيه للدول السودانيه
ويحدث ويؤكد التحول المدني الديمقراطي
المنشود عبر خروج المؤسسه العسكريه من
العمليه السياسيه وقيام حكومه مدنيه تنتهي
بمراحل الانتقاليه تقوم في اخرها انتخابات
يعبر فيها ويختار فيها الشعب السوداني